that guy before he turns back into a  destructive pile of random junk like the  rear rack man then you screwed up my egg  races now this is just annoyingly loud  because you know I'm just gonna bust out  of this rig and wreck whatever your dumb  plan is a breath the dumb plan is a race  when you can't win to finally show the  world that you're not the fastest thing  alive you'll be a laughing stock has  been you'll be so embarrassed you'll  have to leave town and it's not a dumb  plan it's really quite ingenious a race  and race in my sleep snore way has been  once everyone loses respect for you  you'll never want to get out of that bed  again believe me you know what that's  like  that's pretty impressive wait until you  see the new variety of power tech I'm  going to use to make you the world's  biggest loser that's impressive